Oh good morning, Hank, it's Tuesday.
I didn't see you there, I was busy working
on my new book in my usual novel writing position.
Anyway, today's video comes to you in 4 parts.
Part 1: Johning
So the nice people at The Hollywood Reporter
wrote an article about The Fault In Our Stars
movie and me, and they included this picture,
and then long-time nerdfighter Emily posted
a picture of herself doing what she called
"johning".
And then Charlie McDonnell did one, and then
began a massive flood of johning including
Josh Sundquist, and this very small person,
and you, Hank and lots, and lots of other
people.
Anyway Hank, the cast of the movie thinks
that johning is hilarious, as do I, so I just
wanted to say, thank you for johning.
Part 2: Your birthday!
Hank it was your birthday yesterday.
Happy Birthday!
Unlike last year I did remember to get you
a present this year from me and also from
nerdfighteria.
The original arcade game, Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles.
TMNT for life, Hank!
This is a real tattoo by the way, is that
weird?
*whispers* It's not a real tattoo.
Also Hank, I got you a donation to Partners
in Health.
Partners in Health, for actual life.
Part 3: Hank Green and the Perfect Strangers
It just occurred to me that this video is
going to have more than 3 parts.
I apologize for that.
Why does my hair look so like weird and grown
up and professional?
Hank, your excellent new album Incongruent
comes out tomorrow, so nerdfighters, that
means that today is the last day that you
can pre-order a signed copy.
There is a link in the doobly-doo.
Also, for those of you who prefer your goods
and services digitally, the album will be
out on iTunes tomorrow.
Hank, I don't want to get all Esther Day-y
on you or anything, but when I was listening
to the album, I was reminded of what a great
musician you are in addition to all the other
things you do, and I really admire you and
the way that you go about your work.
I'm getting Esther Day-y.
Anyway Hank, long story short, you're not
that cool, you're a grapefruit.
Part 4: The many headless and/or faceless
people in my hotel room
So Hank I'm doing all this like TFiOS press
junket stuff with the cast of the movie and
they put us in a very nice hotel, but there
are a lot of people in my room with no heads.
This person has no head.
This person, also no head.
No head.
And then there are these people who I think
have heads but definitely do not have faces.
This guy has half a face which by the standards
of this hotel room puts him in like the top
1% of facedness.
Part 5: Tour
So Hank, the Fault In Our Stars movie stuff
is starting to like actually happen now.
Like we just had our first screening for fans
of the book, which was nuts!
And most importantly, they liked the movie.
Like Hank, I guess I want the movie to do
well, but to be completely honest with you,
ultimately what I want is for people who care
about the book a lot to like the movie.
And I got to sit in the back of the theatre
for like the last fifteen minutes of the movie
and I heard quite a lot of sobbing, which
I found very encouraging.
Anyway, now, starting today actually, I get
to go on tour with Shailene and Ansel and
Nat.
Okay for of these the doors will open at 5,
and the show will start around 6:30.
This is Fox's tour, not mine, so I seriously
have no idea what's going to happen but I
do know that it's free!
Today, we will be in Miami, Florida at the
Dolphin Mall.
Is it an actual dolphin?
Is it a gigantic dolphin that they turned
into a mall?
That seems like animal cruelty.
Wednesday, we will be in Cleveland at the
Tower City Center.
Thursday, we will be in lovely Nashville,
Tennessee at the War Memorial Auditorium at
the Tennessee Performing Arts Center, and
Friday, May 9th we'll be in Dallas, Texas
at the South Side Ballroom at Gilley's, or
possibly Jilley's.
Like I said earlier, I don't know much about
what's gonna actually happen at these events,
but I know there won't be signings because
they're just expecting a lot of people.
But there will be like Q&A and general merriment.
I think it'll be a lot of fun.
Hank, congratulations again on your great
album and thank you for being such a good
friend and brother to me in this great but
also very weird time of my life.
DFTBA, Nerdfighteria!
Hank, I will see you on Friday.